um
let's start with uh jasir i really love
your character that you play he kind of
reminds me of like
a christmas james bond in some ways and
i'm curious
how much of him how much of yourself you
brought to that character
uh i feel like i really poured my all
into it
you know after seeing like all these big
movie stars
and how well they're doing and what
they're doing for the crew i felt like
you know i would really have to step up
my game what were some of your
strategies and stepping up your game i
love that
um you know having my acting coach help
me out
and you know getting a better
understanding yeah i love that
um for you tyrese your character
has to kind of walk a fine line of being
a good partner to the mother but not
upset
not upsetting the apple cart and i'm
curious how you approached walking that
line maybe even as it relates to
joining a franchise in the middle of the
series
you know honestly man i i just operate
from a place of gratitude you know
um they could have called anybody for
this role and opportunity so when i
showed up
i was just so grateful to be there it's
my first netflix movie
and um i'm like you know
uh this is let me see yeah this
is sequel or franchise number four for
me
yeah i can't believe you know morbius
fast transformers and now this
even though i wasn't a part of part one
of christmas chronicles i also wasn't a
part of fast one so hopefully we can do
this
for many years to come i'm not
interested in being a part of 20
franchises but i
i do appreciate i do appreciate the
energy of this one having nothing to do
with anything else that i've done
so it's uh i'm very grateful and i love
kurt
you know the director was great and this
guy right here this young king and this
sweater right here was a
a real inspiration to work with man i
hope my 11 year old one day will
come close to measuring up to his talent
thank you hi praise for the young king
uh jasir are there any franchises you
would love to be a part of
definitely a marvel movie yeah
i mean that's just like my go-to um but
yeah i would love to be in a
marvel movie who would you love to play
i don't know
see a kid with super powers
it's kind of like it's kind of like kid
flash in a way
i would like to have super powers
superpowers to do
like some special effects but
probably the young black panther i think
that's a great call
um final question for the both of you
there's this really lovely moment the
two of you have where you do this cool
trademark handshake with each other and
i'm curious what the process was
choreographing that rehearsing that
doing that on set how did that come to
be
wouldn't you like to know
i'd much rather jazeer tell the story
well it's really crazy to be honest
you know i was just coming out of my
trailer to go to set
and he was coming out of his trailer too
and we go saw each other this is
actually my first time meeting mr gibson
so when i saw him i was really excited
but i was like kind of nervous at the
same time
and he just and like you know we talked
and he was like we should make a
handshake
and you know i was just down to do it
and we made it and
i never really expected it to come this
far it's crazy
[Laughter]
yeah we made it up we made it smooth the
director was like oh i love that i love
that
and you know it just handshakes and
kind of having those little moments like
ah you know what i mean
and just whatever it's just it just says
like well y'all wouldn't have that if
y'all wasn't actually close so beyond
i'm playing the role of a father and
he's playing the role of a son
i wanted people to know that we really
we really do this thing